hey it's math codec so I was talking to
you from my car a little about a subject
of coding
I know high fidelity car sounds all that
yep so I was just thinking about coding
style you know I was thinking about this
particular question is it important
that's very simple question I know and a
very broad subject its coding style
important and the simple answer is yes
but the long answer is it's complicated
and it's also a double-edged sword and I
will explain that if you'll stick with
me for a few minutes here I'll try to be
quick and explaining this and I'm just
curious whether people have the same
mentality about this or what so I'm
curious to hear comments and see what go
so basically what I was thinking about
this and it worked a couple coding jobs
one of them where style didn't matter at
all it was all about doesn't work or not
it doesn't do the right thing and and
the other one was or with a team and it
was like yeah code style battle mattered
a lot you have to match the standard
everybody kind of does the same thing
you check in your code it should be up
to standard standard syntax and
everything so yeah it's it's important
when you're working with the team
for a lot of different reasons anything
has made couple things I'd say our
readability and
your code kind of should be anonymous if
it's for a general project or a company
you shouldn't be able to look at the
code until oh this guy wrote it because
I can tell by this style that way it's
not that doesn't become the point
because oddly enough coders coders are
all about flexing with style for some
reason it's like oh I use four spaces
how many spaces do you use I don't use
spaces I use tabs I use two spaces oh
I'm going to use two spaces and then
everybody runs our auto format tool
Andrey does a whole file on every
check-in of change in the spacing and
then it just get into correct info it's
like oh it looks like what's his
neighbor of this then you go to if you
like David you're writing this maybe you
can oh man what were you thinking that
first is like oh I didn't write that
and they're like what then why is it and
say you wrote it so I go you got to look
further back on the get lint
look look further back it's like oh you
just corrected the formatting three
different times so it looks like you
wrote it at this point but you did and
you know that's just one thing but it's
it's just a big annoyance so usually
what happens is everybody has a standard
they adhere to as far as naming schema
the schema or scheme I don't know anyway
Nate as far as how you're gonna name
your variables private public and
whatnot and that's totally up to have
your company wants to do it or how you
want to do it
but everybody's got to kind of get on
that page if they're on one project and
not and it just becomes chaos and it's
an additional frustration that has
nothing to do with the logic everything
and it's just like now we're spending
time discussion of stuff and messing
with stuff has nothing to do with the
project like I explained messed with so
any the basic point is you want to be
able to just get down to the engineering
into the logic of what you're working on
when you're programmer you don't wanna
have to mess with all that stuff and
when you're working on your own stuff
you'll develop your own style and that's
fine it's funny I was streaming on
Twitch and I was just kind of code in a
way and some guy pops in and just starts
ragging on everything I don't I don't
know it's pretty funny to me in
retrospect especially in no I I
appreciate the guy and I thought he
seemed pretty cool but it was just it
was just interesting for it to just have
someone jump in not understand what I'm
working on or have anything to do with
anything not even a follower not even
done a subscriber and they're like no
one I knew just some random dude popping
in and he just starts raggin on stuff
like all this line I don't prefer that
way that's the old sea style you got to
do it this way where's your defines at
the top it's like I don't know I kind of
I answer all this stuff and like but it
got me thinking you know these were some
good questions he was asking why is he
so darn concerned like what's it matter
to him you know I would understand if
like
maybe maybe he was analyzing me up and
saying is this guy worth fallin is
someone I can learn from maybe maybe
that's the case maybe he decided no so
he didn't follow them and that's fine
you know that's fine but I'd like to
think maybe he learned something you
know they hear there's something out of
about other every conversation otherwise
what's the point and sometimes you know
it's always good
I believe communication is always good
that's kind of why I'm pushing through
and doing stuff like this YouTube
channel I'm talking about it or I'm
really interested in it and I like I
like hearing about it so and that's
that's my whole thing with with coding
style whether it's important or not and
I know that was a way to live longer a
little longer than I thought it would
but basically then you know like I said
the basic answer is yeah it's it's
important but it's not like so important
that you should be spending tons of time
on inches
it's just one of those things
that every every person okay so I think
this is what goes into style
coding is an art to some people yeah
that's some people it's a way of getting
stuff into the computer and I guess to
everyone is like that but there are some
people who view it as more of a form of
art and I'm kind of one of those people
I'll admit maybe that's something that
system engineers or whatever don't I
don't know maybe they do more but I
believe there's a part two about
everything especially when it comes to
design and good logic design there's a
form of art to it when you like look
look it like I don't just any really
nice construction you you can always
feel the appreciation just like wow the
design of that thing you can tell it's
solid it holds well you can see how it's
supposed to flow and it don't have to
overthink it to really figure anything
out that that's where the style is
important because and that's how you
kind of want it to read and what reads
easy or good to you might not be easy or
good to another person and then and
that's not super important unless you
have that agreement you have that
agreement it's like well we gotta get it
cleaned up for check-in and it could be
important though based on compilers
that's that's another sort of a sort of
a side last thing I'll say is oh geez
compiler versions and compiling on
different systems it's something really
critical to consider also when styling
because well like the claim formatting
for example
it's a lot different than this standard
Microsoft Visual Studio or canoe style
and even then there are some differences
but the main thing is if it's got a
compile on all the compilers that you're
supposed to support and still fit this
style so that can matter doesn't always
but another thing that should be
considered I'm sure people do consider
alright well that's enough of me ranting
and raving on this video about that hope
you guys enjoyed and let me know your
comments below see you guys in the next
video
happy holidays peace out